the conjuring universe continues to
expand apparently we got our first look
at the conjuring three
we're gonna watch this right now i
don't know what the plan let's just
watch it let's see all i know is james
wants on directing that's all i know
let's see what's in store
[Music]
we know there are other stories to tell
but we've never felt the pressure
oh cool do we feel like there is a great
story to tell and that we have
don't worry the nun origins will be
great though
i really wanted country three to get
away from the haunted house setup
of the first two conjuring films it
should be more on a
whole different level something that
we've never explored before in the
country well we wanted to
keep our new story grounded in the feel
of conjuring movies
but we wanted to make sure we were
telling a brand new story and
we said the art johnson story was
something that really deserved a much
closer look
okay as i got to the bottom of the
stairs
and i went to open the door i don't
remember anything from that point
the next thing i know i was in a jail
cell
and i said what's going on here and they
say well you're
being charged for murder i said what are
you talking about
the trial of arnie cheyenne johnson this
was an internationally
oh this sounds like a great way to go
about this
yeah in the united states that demonic
possession was used as a reason
for committing manslaughter do you think
you'll be able to prove the existence of
the devil in court
you're in for a much different that's
true 100 films
what's the point of a sequel if you
can't out shine and out story
and out heart the previous films
just requires you to bring your a plus
game
when i was working with michael sharps
on my orona i saw a filmmaker that
really
gets these kind of films it's
bittersweet for me
i don't think the critics did
it's good to get a fresh take on where
we can take the conjuring universe
we're offering something very special
with these films and i think that's one
of the reasons people keep coming back
the final reason of course is that
people love to be scared
i don't know that anybody has crafted or
created better scare sequences
than james wan david sandberg
gary dominant corn hardy john lee and
eddie
michael chavs guys were making contracts
right it's gonna be awesome
these are all people that really know
what they're doing i'm looking for an
incredible
job crafting new and original scare
sequences that's really what people come
back to see
wow interesting okay i like it i like
what we're hearing so far taking it
further out into the real world
i mean i'm excited for it uh it looks
really cool i think the conjuring films
are the best part of the
conjuring universe in and of himself i
like the idea that they want to steer
away
from the haunted house motifs even
though i thought the first two were
pretty incredible
i like this idea of getting involved in
a pretty big
trial something like this case of arnie
johnson i've never heard of this before
but it kind of has a bit of that like
exorcism of emily rose touch to it
courtroom drama going on while also
getting demon possession investigation
the plot of that sounds
really cool somehow the crooked man ties
it i bet that's just gonna be like the
beginning
it'll be the moment where they remind us
that he's got his own movie and he
should be looking out for that in the
nearby yeah probably
i feel like that's going to be like the
beginning scene the way how they usually
have something at the beginning before
we go into the actual plot
but it seems like it's going to be very
different i don't know anything about
arnie johnson everybody like kill his
family or something like that i mean it
seems like he
at least committed some brutal act of
manslaughter at the very least as they
uh
credited the crime there in the little
excerpt oh so it's a bit of like a
shining case
so it's not exactly the end of the
horror movie we've been getting but
something completely different that
involves a trial i like that
and i like the reasoning that they're
giving for wanting to steer away do
something different to have more heart
and all that because
the first two had a really good family
vibe to it
and it sounds like we're not really
going to be getting that this time
around
you know yeah although i do like the
idea that you know vera farmiga touched
on of adding even more
of everything in a sequel including
heart and i would hope that maybe
they'll tell a different kind of
dramatics or like maybe
the arn johnson in the movie will be you
know a bit more
of a pull just individually to you know
that sort of heart and that sort of
anguish that i'm sure that guy had to go
through
it's a fascinating story and i love yeah
that idea that we're gonna take this out
into a more public environment and
explore the themes of demonic possession
and ghosts and whatnot from
that vantage point i have to imagine
that we will get you know ghost
spooky jump scares or haunted house-y in
and of themselves and i can't imagine
this film won't have them the ending bit
of this was all about the scares and
stuff
my main concern is that the director of
this as much as james juan is backing
him here uh he did lie rona right
yeah i don't know if he wrote it because
like there are things about some of
these conjuring sequels where i'm like i
didn't much care for this but it had
some
mood i have it still at the same time
you know
yeah it's not the most inspiring thing
to hear when the conjurings
title films are the yeah are some of the
brightest spots
of the overall franchise that it's
leading but i can't wait for an official
trailer i feel like one is right around
the corner i can't wait to see what's in
store
guys what'd you think of this first look
footage you excited for the direction
they're going leave your thoughts down
below
subscribe click that notification bell
catch you guys soon hit the like button